les tablettes numériques font leur
entrée au collège à l'initiative du
conseil général et du centre régional de
documentation pédagogique de l'académie
de versailles 120 tablettes sont mises à
disposition des élèves de quatre
établissements des yvelines dont le
collège alexandre dumas à maurepas le
collège de l'avion également à elancourt
une expérimentation qui fait suite à une
opération en 2011 par l'association
initiative terrain à elancourt et ses
tablettes numériques qu'en pensez vous
faut-il qu'elles se développent dans les
écoles nous sommes allés poser la
question à quelques saint quentinois
à première vue quand on utilise le
l'outil numérique avec les tableaux
numériques ça plaît aux élèves mais on
perd encore un petit peu de temps ça
peut être bien parce que
aujourd'hui on est dans l'ère de
l'informatique donc c'est bien de de
faciliter l'apprentissage par ce genre
de moyens
après est ce que c'est bien long terme
ça je sais pas pour les plus petits je
sais pas mais pour les autres c'est très
très bien c'est comme tout je pense
qu'il faut que ce soit un modération
avec modération et puis utiliser à bon
escient le
enfin l'évolution n'a toujours pas que
des mauvais côtés je pense que il faut
pas et fermé non plus à tout mais il
faut en faire bon usage
autre information autour du numérique
avec toujours dans la ville d'elancourt
elle vient de recevoir sa troisième
@ cette distinction qui récompense les
efforts en matière d'interactivité et de
services à la population sur son site
internet une récompense décernée par
l'association des villes internet
ces services c'est par exemple le
nouveau portail famille et le soutien
scolaire en ligne gratuit les démarches
administratives en ligne et
l'application sur mobile et puisque l'on
parle d'applications sur mobile la ville
de maurepas développe également une
application dédiée au magazine municipal
pour les tablettes numériques sous
android ou souhaits système apple
également les possesseurs d'un ipad ou
d'une tablette peuvent donc désormais
s'abonner gratuitement en téléchargeant
l'application se e-magazine maurepas est
disponible dès à présent et d'ailleurs
si vous êtes amateur de toutes ces
nouvelles technologies nous en parlerons
tout à l'heure lors de la chronique de
l'innovation avec valérie auribeau nous
parlons du l'ifi ce nouveau moyen de
transmettre des informations à travers
la lumière
auparavant nous allons parler
d'environnement donc avec les 30 ans de
votre votre association pardon madame
jeanne drecq lieu ce soir sur notre
plateau on va juste qu'ils étaient un
petit peu ce plateau pour se rendre à
versailles où se déroulait une nouvelle
étape du bike and run vous ne connaissez
pas vous allez découvrir générique 300
équipes adultes 180 équipes jeunes
reporté en raison de la neige le bike
and run 2013 aura finalement tenu toutes
ses promesses ce week end on va s'amuser
plus qu'autre chose on n'y va pas pour
faire un chrono passer du bon temps
un parcours d'environ 13 km dans le parc
du château de versailles autour de la
pièce d'eau des suisses vtt et course à
pied en équipe au delà de l'aspect
physique la compétition met également
les neurones à contribution à quel
moment effectué le relais avec son
binôme
quelle est la meilleure tactique à
mettre en place ce qui est important
c'est de dans les dents les run and bike
c'est surtout de préparer avec son
coéquipier les changements de vélo
notamment pour avoir un peu une
stratégie en fonction des parcours c'est
ça qu'est le final mais assez important
si la plupart des concurrents venaient
en amateur les sportifs de haut niveau
ont signé de bonnes performances une
occasion pour eux de préparer les
prochaines compétitions de triathlon à
la victoire revient au duo ferreira
combaluzier en 44 minutes et 15 secondes
effectivement j'ai gagné les quatre
éditions précédentes avec quatre
équipiers différents l'idée c'est que
j'essaie d'avoir toujours un cinquième
un équipier différence par année mais je
suis un jeune papa avec un petit garçon
un petit noé de 11 mois et je suis passé
on va dire de plus de 15 heures
d'entraînement par semaine à 5
donc c'était pas du tout fait j'ai eu un
équipier hors norme cette année et puis
c'est vrai que le bike and run c'est
quand même une de mes disciplines de
prédilection qui correspond à mes
qualités physiques
c'était un parcours assez c'est assez
beau avec
les bonnes cotes à monter aussi des
rêves une grosse cote de 300 m ces raids
oui il y avait beaucoup de beaux essais
glisse on n'a pas d'appuis
c'est assez dur prochain rendez-vous à
versailles le championnat de france avec
elle le triathlon du roi les 11 et 12
mai